Today's topic. Let's put this up there on the screen.
This is a new wall street journal investigation. Quote,
men are abandoning higher education in such numbers.
They now trail female college students by record levels.
So get this in 2020, the college gender gap has searched.
59% of students are women.
40.5% of college students are men.
And if you look even further, Marshall, it is predominantly young white men,
regardless of class status, both poor and those,
but when you compare poor and working class white men, to those of young, black,
Latino, and Asian men from the same economic backgrounds,
they are the ones who are kind of leading the way in dropping out. So look,
there's always gonna been a little bit of an imbalance within college,
but 60 40 all within a year, and a dramatic increase in that,
especially whenever it comes to socioeconomic status is absolutely crazy is
gonna change higher education for a long time. So what's going on here? Well,
it's not just.
Gonna change, change higher education. It's gonna change our country. Yeah.
Right? Because the key fact in this wall street general report,
I's probably pay walled,
but I really recommend people try to find it as much as they can.
Cuz once again, this is actually,
I don't wanna overstate this a game changer as we look to how the next couple
decades are gonna play out 70, there's been a, there's been a huge,
actual decline in the number of in was enrolled in college,
the past decade and 71% of that decline mm-hmm <affirmative> is driven by young
men. Like that is, that is, that is the key factor. Good.
People are saying they don't want to do it.
And they're making that conscious choice. Great. Listen.
University is not tenable for most folks having to take out hundred thousands of
dollars in through student loans.
Even 50, 60 degree ran with interest and all that stuff.
It's untenable considering also the fact that the return on investment,
isn't very high for a lot of these degrees crazy. Isn't it?
So knowing that knowing that young men are saying, listen,
I'm not gonna up my whole life.
Take on all this debt and shackle myself to a degree. That one,
I probably don't even know if I wanna do cuz who the knows what they want to do
when they're 18 brother at 18,
I don't even know where I want to stick my Dick in.
You wanna tell me to tell you why I could choose my future brother?
Are you mad? That's crazy. You're moving mine. That's crazy.
You're moving mine.
And you're telling me I have to make a choice and take on debt, bro.
This is a lose lose, and it's gonna be a lose lose and 20 years.
So it's just LS all day.
Then I get to school. I'm stressed out.
Don't enjoy it in the next four years of my life are just absolute trash.
If I didn't pick correctly,
ni and I gotta suffer with that decision forever.
There are people literally running away from this country cuz they don't want to
pay their student lumps. So what I'm not gonna be going crazy. Of course,
young men are quitting. This thing, this college system is untenable.
It makes no sense. It's untenable for everybody. No sense.
And the fact that we pressure young folks into making this decision and telling
them this is a way forward.
It's not like these are lazy. People want to stay home and smoke weed all day.
All right me, I know this. I know young dudes want responsibility.
They want to work.
And so they go out and they join the labor force and they'll do manual labor.
You tell 'em to go on a construction field.
Vast majority of them all join the next day and they feel proud and they feel
good because they know that the labor and the work that they paid in put in,
comes back to them. When you go to university, it's a bit more ephemeral.
It's a little bit harder to grab.
It's like seeing in your hand it keeps slipping out. That's not a great feeling.
Not when you are looking for stability. Oh you wanna work, sir? Well, okay.
You work. Give me 50 grand. First what? <laugh> nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah.
It's just it's. It is not. So I understand the frustration that they feel.
And if they're making this conscious choice to say, listen, I'm lost,
but I'm not gonna make this reckless choice.
That history is shown is probably not gonna be to my benefit.
Good for these men man. And I hope minorities follow suit as well.
If you're not choosing a great field, right?
I do not recommend that you shackle yourself with debt. I don't recommend it.
Take a couple extra years before you make that choice because we are too often.
I know this from an immigrant standpoint, parents speak on it,
put that pressure, speak on it.
They put that pressure and I've seen it break a lot of these kids.
It up a lot of their kids that were supposed to be doctors and had mental
breakdowns and just gave up on everything. Yo, you shoulds,
you should've seen my parents when my sister went from,
from health science right. To, to teaching because here's the thing,
there's what your parents want you to be and who you are. Yeah.
And these things are constantly pulling at you up from both extremes. Yeah.
And so I think from people from minority backgrounds,
they're living through that exist, sink exists. And if you're fortune,
if you're one of the lucky ones who you are happens to be pretty decently close
to what your parents want you to do. So you might luck out,
but most people don't have that experience.
So I think the reason why this trend is so different between minority
backgrounds and white folks is I think just the messaging is very, very,
very different in that regards. And that pressure you get at is different.
It comes from a different place and more so that's the only way that at some
point that minorities could advance. Yeah. That's Wendy could, uh,
because you gotta bring your mama out the hood, you gotta bring your dad,
pull everybody out, right. Or if you're an immigrant, well,
we came to this country to give you a good life. So if you're not gonna do it,
you're not gonna live your dreams. You're gonna work.
So if young men are saying, no, I'm not gonna jump into this. Good for you guys.
Listen, you're talking to a high school dropout, which I don't recommend.
But what I'm trying to say is education wasn't for me.
And I could see the writing on the wall.
I went to orientation day for university to go see what it was like.
So I sat down on a criminology lecture and I fell asleep and I said,
I'm not paying the sleep at school. I could nap for free in my bed,
save some money and make my own choices. Cuz guess what?
If there's one thing my mom taught me other than go to school, love your money.
It just so happens. That's the only lesson I listen to.
<laugh> shout out to mom. Okay. I lack my money.
That's why I always had a bit in the savings. Why?
Cause I didn't like having zero. All right.
I would rather starve and wear the same clothes all day than have no money in my
bank account. Okay. Hey, shout out to you. MABA I never had debt.
That's one best lessons. My mom taught me. You can't pay for it.
You don't play with it. Okay?
If you can't afford to play burn, don't play. If you can't afford to play,
stay away. Hey that's right.
That was real. That's the only lesson you listen. Listen, that is one.
My mom, she worked a lot. So she couldn't be present too often,
but that lesson stuck with my whole life and I never had no issue with credit as
a result. Yeah. In terms of finances, I understand it for folks.
And I think, I think here's an interesting thing.
Go in. So we're speaking at so social place.
I think this is gonna change the way work is gonna work, right?
The way the whole like employment landscape is gonna look completely gonna
change. Cuz all these men who are gaining experience,
but yet don't have like the necessary paperwork for degrees.
Employers are gonna have to start looking differently at who they gonna hire.
Right. Cuz they need competence over, over, over, over paperwork and you know,
right. Go ahead. So employers are gonna have to look at things very differently.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> right. So it's gonna change the work landscape for one two.
It's gonna completely change the dating landscape. Oh yeah. Ladies,
you gonna have to start paying for them bills.
You want somebody at your education level. You gonna have to go get it.
You want somebody who's making maybe comparable income, turn the lesbian.
You know what I mean? He might not make as much as you,
but best belief he gonna have less debt than you <laugh> yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. That's right. Yeah.
So it's not gonna be just how much you make. It's like Mitch,
do you got student debt? Let's talk. Okay.
It's about to be a different conversation. Higa me.
If you still playing to that, you going die alone. That going guaranteed. Wow.
That gonna change. It's going change a lot's change, right? Yeah. Oh,
that's going change. Mm-hmm <affirmative> the way people. Yeah.
The way people looking at things. Yeah. So, uh, I got a, a lawyer degree.
I'm doing this. Cool. How's this student L well, Hmm.
I'm 150 down. Oh, okay. Was last talking to you? Yeah. Only a few of you.
Ladies are gonna get in the mine. Crazy. Okay.
Only a few of you ladies gonna get in the gold mine.
Rest of y'all gonna be waiting outside. Just thirsting for gold.
It's not gonna be that many people admitted. Why? Cuz the,
the mine it's starting to run dry. God you it's gonna be a different landscape.
So I'm very looking forward to seeing what is going to happen. Going forward.
I hope for a lot of these folks, they find some, uh,
measure of comfort in the employment sector and doing work and finding like
Joyce and just like labor, you know? How long do you think the,
the switch is gonna happen? Five years? Oh no. I think this is permanent. Oh no,
no, no. The switch I'm writing down. No, this like,
people are gonna look the way people are gonna look at at, at uh,
dating and everything. And when, when, when is it starting? Oh,
it's already been starting. Yeah.
It's already been starting because these trends have already showcased
themselves. Remember that video we did earlier about like down dating down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. That's only going to, that's only gonna,
it's gonna be more, more and more.
And so this whole idea of like traditionally the masculine,
the man makes more and all this other stuff that may not necessarily be true in
some time. So what do you think about what you just heard?
I could try to analyze it. I mean, and it's white people that white,
white men that are not going to the school. Right? Men in general,
but white men are driving it.
We spent the last couple of years saying that the white man were the problem.
White man were leading the world. White man were winning, winning,
winning smooth generation. Doesn't want to be that.
There's that there's the fact that, you know, everything changed every, every,
every, every there's stick to allergy has changed everywhere. Cars,
phones, computers,
a classroom has been the same since Charman, south Charman.
The guy that invented the, or put that made that, uh, mandatory.
It didn't, it, it, it never really appealed. The boys.
We just is winging because that's the thing that we had to do them dropping out.
I can understand. I can understand. I just dunno why it didn't happen sooner.
I mean, I had to complete school. If I took my, my, my experience,
I had to complete school. I said to myself, at least,
let me just finish this high school, cuz I'm already done. 'em enough.
And I'm already, already not supposed to be here.
Cuz every teacher that I'm having are telling me that I'm not supposed to be
here. I'm not ever gonna accomplish anything in life.
So let me just at least finish that. I'm already stupid as. Right?
Let me prove them that I can finish this. So I did, but it took me a lot.
And after the, I went to college because that was the thing to do.
And I remember my parents,
I had this discussion with my parents and my parents was like,
I wanna see your report card. Cause I'm paying. So you see me? My, you, I, I,
I know they said I'm paying. I decide. And when I went to college, I said, word,
I got myself a job and I pay my tuition. And at some point my,
my dad came to me and said like, oh, let me see your report card.
And I was like, no, be remember how it works.
I pay, I keep my report card.
But I re really just stayed two semesters there because I said,
I'm paying so I can make the choice. And this was really not for me.
And I left and I tried to twice, like after that, I went to,
I tried to go to university every time I try to go back to school. It's funny.
There's something that it's always something that pulled me out.
And I've always been able to find more outside than in
school and a society that I understood. The society that we live in.
Every time you got a paper, they would ask you for experience.
So it was actually just better to go out there and have experience.
So I never went back cuz you need experience.
You're gonna come out with a paper with a diploma and a still gonna
ask you for like five years experience.
So I might as well just start from the bottom in this company,
learn the nooks and crannies of everything and go up riding to go to school.
And then I could use that and it's been working like that.
So I can't understand at some point that if I just based it on my experience,
that people would not try to go to school.
It's not granted that you're gonna be, you're gonna have this big diploma.
And then after that,
a lot of people that I know are not working in the field that they,
and I'm not talking about doctors, not.
I talk about people that are Pharmac pharmacists and stuff like that.
But other fields,
there's a lot of fields that they're not working in the fields that they
studied. So I don't know. I don't know if it's their,
whether it's talking to them.
I don't know if it's their experience or anything like that.
But if I take it from my experience, I'm like, Ugh, I don't know, man. Anyways,
I think this is super interesting. I think this is a very,
very telling trend. So I've noticed this is already well,
well documented,
but just seeing how exponentially faster it's to all the young men watching,
not telling y'all not to go to school. I'm just saying,
make the decision responsibly. Don't do it.
Cuz the world tells you do it because that's what you want.
And if you don't want to, it's okay to just live in uncertainty.
It's okay to not just take a random action because you're,
you don't know what to do with your life. Okay. All right.
We don't need another 10,000 people.
People transferring into psychology cuz they like brains and they find out the
major that they initially chose is dog. All right. Take your time.
I like brains, but for different reasons <laugh>
I just like getting ahead. So anyways,
let us know what you're asking in the comment below and if you enjoy today's
video, like comment, I was getting, getting, getting some no.
Oh
good.
Go.